now comes the news courtesy of
mike silver of nfl media who also went
to cal
just like aaron rodgers not speculating
on who his sources well he always knows
he always knows jared goff and aaron
rodgers news i'll say that i'm
just pointing out they both went to cal
that's all i'm saying
but uh silver reports not with rogers as
a source
that that uh the packers are working on
restructuring
aaron rodgers contract to create cap
space now
there was another report out there
pointing out that the packers already
have and this is a fairly common tool
you have the ability baked into the
existing contract
to do a simple restructuring whenever
you want where you take the total
compensation for the year
reduce it to the minimum salary turn the
rest into a signing bonus
and it gives you a smaller cap number
you no longer need in some of these
contracts the permission
of the player to do it not that there's
any reason for the player to say no the
player's getting all of his money right
now right
it's all in hand right now but if the
player wants to be a jerk
you know what's in it for me the player
can be and say well what's in it for me
well you want it helps you what does it
do for me well maybe i want something
more and the fact that there's even a
negotiation
suggests that it is something more than
just
creating cap space by moving money
around
so that's what's fascinating to me chris
because
i was told back in that window after the
nfc championship lost to the bucks
right he wants a new contract not
because he wants new money
but he wants a contract that is
structured in a way that makes it clear
that the packers are tied to him you
know these contracts are always one way
at a minimum where the player is tied to
the team
and after you get through the early
years of the contract and the guarantees
go away
the team can rip it up whenever they
want and the packers are now in a year
to year arrangement
i think aaron rodgers wants and deserves
more than a year to your arrangement and
this may be the framework
for getting that done yeah this is where
i you know i i mean i hear everything
you're saying
i just is is this about that right
and and you know roger's getting yes you
know a little bit more security here to
go like okay wait i'm still one of the
best players in the league uh
if not like number two only behind you
know number 15 at kansas city
why don't i have a little bit more of a
team that's you know giving me a future
here
i understand that thought completely i
do
i also sit here and think mike i don't
know i mean you know they're what where
are they sitting right now
little more than three million dollars
under you know under the the salary cap
number
as far as uh you know the penalty
whatever it may i'm
blanking on the way to phrase that but
you know
are they are they doing this to make a
move here too that's the other thing i
think about
you know is there is there something
that we're not seeing is a ty hilton on
their radar
and they just want to have a little
extra money to get a guy like i don't
think it's going to take a ton of money
and we're seeing what the wide receivers
are going for
you know guys like aj green t-y hilton i
mean i think a lot of them are going to
be one
year underwhelming type deals are they
looking to make a move to help out the
team the offense rogers
or is this simply something about
they're looking at you know down the
line trying to figure out their team i
don't know but that's what's crossed my
mind
it may not be about selling right at all
right
that may be the way that rogers told it
to silver
if rogers was silver source because
rogers does not
want to be characterized in a negative
light by anyone
it's almost an obsession with him and
when you look at
the way russell wilson has been
aggressive with the seahawks
this year the way that desean watson had
been aggressive with the texans
a week ago and prior to that before
everything changed with deshaun watson
this desire to never be characterized in
a negative light by anyone and
specifically not by packers fans i mean
i can understand it because he witnessed
the venom
that ultimately was directed at brett
favre when it was clear
the packers wanted to move on from farv
to rogers
the packers fans got mad that farv
ultimately didn't go along with that
plan
and walk off into the sunset when the
packers didn't want him playing for them
anymore so i think that's part of it
he doesn't want to be perceived as
greedy he doesn't want to be perceived
as rocking the boat
but look i'm looking at his contract
right now his average salary is thirty
three and a half million dollars you
know who's making thirty three and a
half million dollars per year
jared and carson wentz yeah
right negative ghost rider that doesn't
make sense i mean yeah
forget forget about mahomes and dak and
anyone else
when when aaron rodgers the mvp
of the national football league in 2020
is making the same as
one guy who was in the middle of a storm
of dysfunction
in philly right and but for the colts
there wouldn't have been any other team
that wanted him to take on that contract
frankly
at this point and jared goff who was
who was hidden in the matthew stafford
contract
to conceal the fact that it was a brock
osweiler hot potato move
to give the lions net draft assets to
take goff off the roster
that those two guys are making the same
as aaron rodgers
and rogers is smart enough to look at
that and say something's wrong with this
picture
and something is wrong with that picture
he's perfectly justified
in wanting more but more than anything
else wanting to know
that the packers are not preparing
the moment he shows the slightest
slightest sign of slippage
slightest sign of slippage try saying
that three times fast
to float him on an iceberg and put
jordan loving at quarterback i think
that's what this is all about
and that's what it should be about he's
never gonna have more leverage over the
packers chris
than he has right now coming off of
arguably the best season of his career
yeah i mean i i understand it from aaron
rodgers you know
aspect all the way here i mean yeah of
course yeah
of course he doesn't want to be killed
in the the court of public opinion i
mean i don't know we'll see what happens
with this restructuring i am
curious to see what exactly is gonna be
done or
if there's gonna be more money added to
it or if it's simply like you just said
converting money to guaranteed money and
there's really nothing that needs to be
done there
um but i i would understand aaron
rodgers wanting him more
security i would understand him also you
know worrying about the way he's
perceived and the public
you know he's done everything right for
this football team always
so i don't think he's going to let them
off the hook here you know they haven't
always done
right by him you know so i think that he
is
you know protective of his legacy and
what it means to the green bay
packers fans and all of those type of
things he doesn't want to be perceived
as maybe
you know for lack of a better way
selfish like brett favre was a little
bit on the way out i'm not saying brett
favre was but
you know what i'm i'm trying to say it
was it was a little bit it was a little
bit like hey you guys are going to wait
for me
every year and i'll figure out if i'm
going to play and do all that so
yeah maybe he's going about his business
more in a quiet manner my other big
thing hearing mike is just
you know what do the packers do what do
the packers commit
how much do they want to commit how many
years do they want to commit i mean you
drafted a quarterback in the top 32
picks of the draft in the 2020 draft
i mean what we're gonna it doesn't make
sense if we're gonna wait to year four
to play them
that's where i'd go then see it's a
wasted pick we're four years down the
road we got a quarterback
oh great i mean you're going to pass up
15 other quarterbacks on the way before
the time he finally plays
so that's where i'm interested to see
where this goes too because i want to
see the commitment they're going to make
to them because it is going to give us a
little bit of an
inkling to where they think maybe jordan
love is
or you know you know how committed or
not are they to rogers i think that's a
big
piece of this puzzle and you know we
haven't seen jordan love priests play
preseason football yet
we haven't seen anything so i have no
idea what they think of him or what he
did last year or anything like that and
that's why i'm interested in the
in this whole deal i'm also very
intrigued by the dynamic between rogers
and the front office and ultimately mark
murphy who
is every bit as smart as rogers he
wouldn't be running the green bay
packers
if he wasn't former player an old-timer
so he understands how things are done
pete
and and and i think murphy
smart enough to know how to push the
buttons
on aaron rodgers to get the desired
outcome that he may be looking for
because at the end of the day murphy
knows that rogers
doesn't want to be criticized by
anyone really but especially not by
packers fans
and so what's rogers going to do what's
he going to do is he going to hold out
is he going to demand a trade the most
he's going to do
is make some passive aggressive comment
that he walks back
the moment that someone like me spots it
and
says ha ha he's got a problem with the
green bay packers and he's trying to
subtly let them know it yeah he does
but he doesn't want anyone to notice it
and that's when he gets upset so
i think murphy is smart enough to know
how aaron rodgers
is going to play this game and at the
end of the day
all murphy has to say is we're not doing
that we're not doing that you want that
well sorry you signed a contract through
2023 and i won't put a gun to your head
we've got these rights this is how it
works aaron you've been around long
enough to know you're smart enough to
know
you wouldn't assign that contract you
didn't know that this is what you were
committing to
we can't do it i'm sorry we we we love
you and we want you to be here
but we're not going to rip up this
contract and and make a commitment
that that undermines the duties that we
have to the shareholders of this
organization i i
wouldn't surprise me if murphy takes a
bit of a hard line well you know he he
can do he's not going to win this war in
the the
the court of public opinion against
aaron rodgers he's not it's not going to
happen
but if rogers doesn't if i know he'll
i'm getting confronted a little bit
that's the problem right he can win it
if he wants to yes
but he doesn't want to well he might
have to come to that point if he doesn't
feel like he's getting the security or
support from the organization to where
you know he'll have to take the maybe
somewhat of the unpopular approach
but i'll be there to get us back like i
usually
am right and i'm gonna go yeah me too
and he gets mad about it well okay
i know you know sometimes you you call
him out too and i'm sure he doesn't like
that i mean
um but you know i i will be there to
call we'll be there to back him up in
this case i think
you know specifically because he has a
lot to be
he has a lot in his corner a lot of
evidence that shows like wait he's done
this and you guys have done
not that great in your area whether it's
you know
supporting them with players weapons
everything we've talked about super bowl
window
they never go all in super bowl window
we draft your replacement
when you're still like forget about last
year
which was the best year in the nfl by a
quarterback i mean still
the year before that they went to the
nfc championship game
and there's no arguing that he was one
of the five best quarterbacks in
football
like there was none of it you couldn't
argue with anybody i don't think there's
anybody in the nfl that would have gone
after that 2019 season where they lost
everybody oh yeah roger's still top five
quarterback oh no doubt no doubt no
doubt no doubt no doubt no doubt i mean
there's there's nobody that was gonna
deny that
so i think if it does get to that green
bay better be careful
because i think rogers is
tactically smarter than a brett favre
and
has more bullets on his side for lack of
a better way to say it
to use against the organization to where
if they want to get in a public tiff
roger's going to win and and they're
going to be in
a tough spot yeah i look i agree
with you but he has to be willing to
take the fight to them
and he has been unwilling to do that
over the years he likes to do the little
drive-by snide comment that isn't
obvious to the average person that he's
taking a shot
and then once someone recognizes he made
a drive-by snide comment
that wasn't supposed to be recognized he
he he gets
he gets upset and that's just kind of
the way that it's gone
he deserves more he deserves more than
33.5 million a year
he deserves more security if he wants it
and
he had always said i want to stay with
the packers into my 40s
i want to finish my career here and
they're the ones
last year who put him through that
that rude awakening when they traded up
to get jordan love and i can't imagine
there's a single packers fan out there
that feels good about the fact
that the packers use their fourth round
pick in their first round pick last year
to get a guy who contributed nothing to
the effort right to try to get to the
super bowl right and every
you know it's weird packers fans get mad
when i point that out it's like are you
in that deep of denial
about this that you don't recognize that
your team would have been better off you
don't know a damn thing about jordan
love and if anything it's screwing up
the relationship
in the final days of aaron rodgers right
packers i i i'm and
i'm not saying they should trade jordan
love i don't know what they could get
for him at this point
but they need to renew their vows with
aaron rodgers they need to do the right
thing here
um unless they unless they're just
manipulating him and chris it may
if just like was it wes welker who
played better when he was pissed off
i i i think that they're trying to keep
aaron rodgers
in that in that that that thin area
of sufficiently pissed off that he's
highly effective
but not so pissed off that it creates a
problem for us
i think they're trying to just the right
amount of agitation
for aaron rodgers is what mark murphy's
trying to pull off and you know what
last year
it worked he was the mvp of football
yeah i mean i hear you i don't think
i i don't think that's it though i don't
i don't think you need to do that to
motivate aaron rodgers i think he's got
a motivation to be the greatest of all
time he's that kind of guy
so you know they're okay yeah maybe that
is their tactic
but within doing that tactic they have
hurt their football
team and you know again green bay fans
like
i don't know what you wanted mike to say
there like yeah
you got picks that didn't help out your
football team it's 20 20.
that like the day of like we're gonna
wait three years for this guy to help
our team
that's done that was 1974 thinking
that's
it the team that just won the super bowl
had a starting right tackle who was
drafted in the first round
he was great antoine winfield safety
made great plays
this the the wide receiver from
minnesota made great plays in the
playoffs
i mean so that day of thinking it's
outdated and that's where
if i'm rogers i'm pissed off about all
of those type of things
let alone like i said they you know
we've said they haven't gone all in on
him
and and he's right he's 36 he's going to
be 37
this year you know in this day now
at 36 and 37 that's really like 31 and
32
25 years ago it really is with the way
guys like rogers take care of themselves
yeah he's not like brady totally but
it's not far off for the way he takes
care of himself that way
and he's more physically gifted so i
don't think he's gonna die out anytime
soon you know his arm is like one of
those we talk about mike he's gonna be
throwing lasers when he's in a
wheelchair at 94.
he'll be able to throw a laser still and
his movement yeah it's not like it used
to be but it's still really damn good
and effective so uh yeah you could see i
still don't understand
some of the moves by green bay there by
the way his two-week stint as guest host
of jeopardy is coming up
i can't wait soon i think like within
the next couple of weeks so we're gonna
see
and hear from aaron rodgers plenty and
we'll see whether or not the packers get
this deal
done hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports